michel sapin le ministre du travail est
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous l'emploi l'emploi
l'emploi le chef de l'état veut
accélérer la mise en place du pacte de
responsabilité au moment on peut lire ou
des doutes apparaissent et où les
critiques se renforce à gauche mais
aussi au medef qui est bien décidé
apparemment à ne rien lâcher sur les
contreparties qu'ils ne sont que des
contraintes impossible pour pierre
gattaz et karine perrelle afp vous
donnera l'occasion de lui répondre tout
à l'heure et avec perrine tarneaud de
public sénat nous évoquerons les
difficultés du gouvernement et du
président tombé à moins de 20 % de
bonnes opinions d'abord michel sapin
l'avertissement de la cour des comptes
au moment où le gouvernement cherche on
le sait 50 milliards d'économies que
répondez-vous aux doutes exprimés par
didier migaud sur le redressement des
comptes il le dit qui n'est pas à la
hauteur des objectifs ce qu'il dit
d'abord c'est qu'un effort comme jamais
a été fait vous avez raison de présenter
la partie si je puis dire pile de la
monnaie mais il ya une partie face il
faut aussi regarder cette partie face il
souligne que jamais la france depuis de
très nombreuses années donc jamais un
gouvernement n'avait mis en place des
procédures aussi puissante pour diminuer
notre endettement diminuer notre déficit
et même cette année en 2012-2013 pardon
diminuer les dépenses publiques et ce
qu'il dit il est dans son rôle
il faut aller plus loin c'est d'ailleurs
plus efficace des pigs c'est d'ailleurs
ce que dit aussi le gouvernant où le
président de rappeler qu'il faut aller
plus loin dans les 50 milliards que vous
avez cités d'économies nécessaires on
les cite souvent dans le cadre du pacte
de responsabilité on y reviendra
il ya beaucoup de milliards des dizaines
de milliards qui sont nécessaires au
titre de la diminution de notre déficit
neymar il est donc cet effort nous
continuerons référent part toujours de
cet effort mais le détail des économies
comme le dit le premier président de la
cour des comptes il se fait attendre
non il se fait pas attendre pour 2013 il
a pu juger lui-même du détail de ces
économies et il a même constaté que les
économies que nous avions proposée nous
les avons faites ensuite pour 2014 et à
juste titre il nous dit maintenant il va
falloir nous décrire précisément ses
économies il a parfaitement sow
d'ailleurs il n'est pas le seul à nous
le demandait
dire là aussi dans le cadre du pacte de
responsabilité on nous dit mais ce que
vous allez diminué comme cotisation du
côté des entreprises
comment allez-vous le compenser jusqu'à
présent votre objectif de droite ou de
gauche c'est est compensée par une
augmentation du taux de cotisation ou
d'un impôt non c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fera on le fera avec une diminution
progressive maîtrisé mais forte des
dépenses publiques parce que c'est le
seul moyen aujourd'hui de financer de
manière solide de manière responsable
des allégements de cotisations penser
qu'on arrivera aux 3,6 points par
déficit cette année ou que tout ça
dépendra aussi du niveau de la
croissance
on a un objectif de 0,9 pour cent de
croissance est un objectif est faible
c'est un objectif que dont vous dites
vous même qu'il est faible il a été fixé
de manière très raisonnable par le
gouvernement et la cour des comptes
elle-même considère que ce 0 9% de
croissance pour 2014 est un objectif
parfaitement en ligne avec piqué peut
surveiller les fans et notamment plus
souvent non quand on sait qu'à celles 09
suffisamment dense et encore l'objectif
du pacte de responsables touchaient
d'aller plus loin
d'accélérer comptons accélérer la caisse
q que pensez-vous de la suggestion de
didier migaud de serrer la vis des
prestations sociales se sont comptées
encore en tête quand même ce qu'avait
dit françois hollande lors de ses voeux
il avait parlé d abus 1 sur la sécu
alors laisse que vous seriez prêts
effectivement à s'auto deux ans quand on
parle prenez un jet ski paquet pagre
herbe et si on fait ce geste là chacun
va se trouve à penser que on retire
quelque chose d'indispensable
bon on peut dans le domaine de la
sécurité sociale des prestations
sociales
je rappelle que c'est plus de la moitié
des dépenses publiques donc quand on dit
qu'il faut maîtriser et diminuer les
dépenses publiques ont dit d'abord et
avant tout il faut que dans le domaine
de la sécurité sociale sans rien
remettre en cause de ce qu'on appelle le
pacte social donc des garanties
fondamentales
il faut avoir des économies c'est ce qui
est en train d'être fait c'est salué
d'ailleurs par la cour des comptes dans
le domaine de la santé sans remise en
cause sans qu'on dise on va augmenter le
forfait
non parce qu'on maîtrise mieux les
dépenses de l'hôpital
on met en place des alternatives à
l'hôpital qui coûte moins cher que
l'hôpital et qui sont plus agréables
les impatients et d'ailleurs
de la médecine au pire dans la médecine
il faut aller plus loin c'est la
question des médicaments des génériques
donc on voit qu'il ya toute une série de
mesures qu'il faut continuer à mettre en
place
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire qu'il
faut s'attaquer vraiment à la masse
salariale de la fonction publique il
faut pas s'attaquer là aussi ça marche
mais attention cela est incertain vous
effraie nommé vos termes sont
parfaitement justifiées de réduire la
réaction mais si on pense qu'on peut
mettre en place des réformes profondes
en étant contre en s'attaquant à sa
marche pas la droite nous dit il ya
kayak aille à cannes on est en france il
ya aussi une nécessité de rechercher un
accord un consensus c'est le principe
même du dialogue
est ce que j'appelle moi le dialogue
social à la française c'est le seul
moyen pour la wii je prends la formation
professionnelle granger qui a été
examiné par l'assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière et qui va l'être la
semaine prochaine ici même au sénat
c'est avec plus avec de l'argent non pas
plus d'argent faire beaucoup mieux
beaucoup plus efficace c'est aussi une
bonne manière de faire en sorte non pas
contre mais de faire éventuellement même
en dépensant moins quelque chose qui est
de meilleure qualité est d'accord avec
l'idée qu'il faut réduire le périmètre
de l'état là c'est vraiment une source
d'économie un périmètre a là aussi je
pense que il faut s'interroger sur
chacune des missions de l'air et se
poser la question de savoir si
aujourd'hui telle mission une présence
sur un territoire d'une certaine manière
est adapté aux besoins de la population
d'aujourd'hui il y a des missions qui
évolue c'est au fou pour reprendre un
terme c'est la fin du rabot c'est le
rabot ça consiste en quoi on dit à
l'état chaque ministre t'as qu'à enlever
1 5 % de dépenses
normand lève partout mais si à la fin il
n'y a plus d'essence pour faire tourner
le moteur des voitures des gendarmes
il ya un problème la mission n'est pas
remplie donc on peut plus continuer
comme ça il faut s'interroger de manière
verticale en mission par mission pour
trouver les bonnes solutions à l'elcom
est aussi de faire les échos neige va
vous parler d'un pays michel sapin qui a
une frontière commune avec avec la
france et les autres pays
l'europe vous parlez de la suisse pays
qui vous fait rêver peut-être celle
plein droit le plein emploi 3 5% de
chômeurs et la suisse donc avec ce
référendum pour mettre fin à
l'immigration massive est ce que il y à
un risque aujourd'hui après le
référendum de dimanche pour les
travailleurs français frontaliers ou
ceux qui choisissent de s'exiler dans ce
pays où je prends le prix économie se
porte bien je parle pas de ce qui c'est
qui choisissent d'être suisse ca c
il s'est exilé pour travailler pour
travailler jeunes souvent les exilés
fiscaux entre guillemets ça qui va nous
profiter en quelque sorte du fait qu'il
paye ses côtés parce qu'il ya des gens
qui aujourd'hui sont légitimement
inquiets
ce sont ceux qui aujourd'hui apportent
leur force de travail un pays qui en a
besoin
vous disiez à juste titre que le taux de
chômage y est très faible
parce que ils ont besoin d'avoir des
gens qui viennent des pays d'à côté des
frontaliers pour le ramener leur force
de travail
la première victime de ce référendum que
je respecte
puisque par définition c'est le vote
d'une majorité du 2d des différents
peuples d'ailleurs de suspect la
première victime risque d'être la suisse
d'abord parce que se priver de la force
de travail de ceux qui sont voisins je
sais pas comment ils vont faire en
nombre d'infirmières vous croyez qu'il
ya suffisamment d'infirmières ayant le
tampon suisse de supports dont je rêve
non donc il y aura de vrais problèmes
pour eux mais c'est aussi des vrais
problèmes parce que on peut pas se
fermer aux autres sans que les autres se
ferme à vous il ya ce qu'on appelle la
réciprocité
s'il n'ya plus la libre circulation vers
la suisse il n'y aura plus la libre
circulation de la suisse vers les autres
ce sera la conséquence
donc c'est de tout cela dont il faut
discuter avec la suisse pour éviter au
fond que quelque chose soit mauvais et
pour les suisses et pour les voisins du
sud en françois fillon il est naturel
que la suisse veuille réduire le nombre
d'étrangers chez elle que pensez vous de
cet éclat c'est une parole soit
maladroite soit révélatrice d'une pensée
profonde d'une forme de la droite
j'espérais que monsieur fillon serait
pas là dedans qui consiste simplement à
courir après la pensée est l'expression
du front national français
donc c'est une forme d'alignement sur le
front national en france
qui est une démone maladresse insigne
mais il dit qu'il n'est pas choqué par
exemple par la notion d'immigrés en
fonction des besoins économiques cette
notion de quotas ils vont faire que
c'est de s'appuyer sur le vote en suisse
qui répondent à des caractéristiques un
peu particulière dans un pays qui n'a
absolument pas de chômage
et pour vous remportez ensuite langage
en france me paraît totalement
inattendue sur la question des quotas
d'immigrés mais aujourd'hui nous avons
aujourd'hui nous avons des politiques en
france l'amélioration des politiques
d'immigration qui sont pas des
politiques libres on ne rentre pas
librement sur le territoire français
sauf quand on est ressortissant européen
où ce fils en l'occurrence mais lorsque
l'on vient de l'extérieur de schengen
comme on lit de l'extérieur du
territoire européen
nous on ne rentre pas librement il faut
que ça corresponde à des professions où
on a des besoins en termes de mada donc
aujourd'hui nous avons une régulation de
l'immigration
ce que je n'aime pas attention verte
quand même mais l élection l'est dans
les mêmes conditions qu'auparavant il
n'y a pas eu de modification de ce point
de vue là même plutôt une volonté de
faire respecter la réglementation donc
monsieur fillon premier ministre
disposer des mêmes règles que celles
dont nous disposons aujourd'hui pour
réguler ce qui est normal l'immigration
en fonction des besoins de notre prix
après il ya l'immigration clandestine ça
c'est autre chose heures il faut lutter
contre cette immigration est ce qu
arnaud montebourg dit vrai en disant que
l' avantage qui est offert aux
entreprises d'ores et déjà en attendant
le pacte de responsabilité par le cic le
crédit impôt compétitivité totalement
absorbés par leurs trop cher surévalué
de 10%
il ne l'est pas mais il y à l'oeil à ce
risque donc si la france faisait un
effort de diminution des cotisations et
que pour le même montant quelque sorte
vis-à-vis des pays autres que ceux de
l'euro il y avait une réévaluation du
montant l'euro on perdrait par rapport à
pays en dehors de l'euro l' avantage
compétitif en question donc c'est une
vraie question que la valeur la valeur
de l'euro simplement je rappelle à tout
le monde que 60% notre déficit
commercial
il est temps en euros par rapport à la
zone euro
donc la valeur de l'euro n'a aucun
impact sur 60 % de nos exportations
si nous voulons en pensant et les
entreprises si on vole aux riches
plus si nous voulons exporter plus de
l'allemagne c'est pas une question de
valeur de l'euro c'est une question de
qualité de nos produits d'innovation de
compétences des personnes en activité
dos rond de compétitivité dans tous les
sens du terme
est ce que vous êtes d'accord je vous
cite encore le ministre du réseau seront
productifs maison et qu'il ait rejoint
sur les gaz de schiste par laurent
fabius tous deux s'accordent pour dire
qu'il faut étendre tenter de trouver une
solution propre d'exploiter les gaz de
schiste là aussi ce serait un atout de
compétitivité formidable si on voit ce
qui se passe au sénat j'ai évidemment
quand on a une et une énergie à pas cher
c'est beaucoup plus avantageux que
compte notre cher j'ai pas dit ça du
tout mais vous avez un environnement
saccagé c'est beaucoup plus dommageable
mais contre vous avez un environnement
préservé donc faut faire attention y'a
pas que la question du coût de l'énergie
il ya aussi les conséquences sur les
générations à venir et parfois réparer
les conséquences en question ça peut
être le plus cher dans cinq heures n'est
pas là donc mais personne ne s'est
jamais interdit la recherche
la question c'est de savoir si on
autorise devait faire forer le sol pour
de la recherche aujourd'hui c'est
interdit par l'interdît par nous c'est
interdit par la majorité précédente avec
une loi qui a été votée il n'est pas
question de modifier cette loi votée
également par la gauche comme un loisir
ou bien alors question interdite à
l'énergie un autre avantage compétitif
pour les entreprises françaises c'est le
nucléaire on prête l'intention au
gouvernement de remplacer les centrales
hors d'âge en fait qu'il devienne trop
cher entretenu aujourd'hui par des ep r
comme celui qui construit la manche ne
sais pas d'où sort ce là donc je ne sais
pas commenter une information que je ne
connais pas ou qui n'est peut-être mais
par une information ça tout comme mais
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'il ya une
paix est requis et à flamanville qui
n'est pas encore définitivement
construit et que dans les engagements du
président de la république ça d'ailleurs
fait débat avec les écologistes dans les
engagements du prix dans la plaie qui a
on va jusqu'au bout du chantier de le p
r voilà qui pourrait s'avérer payant par
ailleurs ailleurs des centrales
nucléaires vieilli devenus obsolètes ou
qui coûterait extrêmement cher à devoir
être rénové qui fermeront mais il faut
pas faire d'assimilation entre les deux
mais déjà jean vincent placé le leader
des sénateurs écolo dit que le
gouvernement a cédé au lobby
de dori proglio le patron je cherche à
éviter de commenter des informations qui
n'existe pas ça évite de faire des
couacs pas bien je vous demandais
éventuellement si vous avez des
informations à la matière on va parler
de l'emploi donc michel sapin hélas de
la courbe du chômage qui ne s'est pas
inversée vos outils face à la panne de
croissance qu'on évoquait il ya un
instant sont donc le très discuté on
n'en parlait pas que de responsabilité
les emplois d'avenir et également les
contrats de génération mais ces derniers
ne séduisent pas les entreprises avant
d'accueillir terre ils paieraient de la
fp
marie paule brémaud nous présente
pourtant un exemple concret ça séduit
il faut dans la vendée jugement
catégorique alors vas voir en examen à
tout juste 20 ans antoine a décroché un
cdi j'ai une grande chance juste voilà
après la fin de contrat d'apprentissage
c'est l'entreprise dans laquelle j'étais
au sein de cette moyenne entreprise
magnum il a donc intégré l'atelier
d'électricité grâce à un contrat de
génération c'est pas normal que l'on
conçoive les entreprises soient obligés
d'être aidé pour ça ça devrait être
normal après ça fait un plus pour les
petites entreprises et les moyennes
entreprises trouvent que le contrat de
génération sur le monde système pour
favoriser l'embauché des jeunes et à
l'autre bout de l'entrepôt ce contrat de
génération a fait un autre heureux
patrick je teste les
et pour colorent les photos lancé des
projecteurs à led à 56 ans ce contrat
garantit à patrick son travail pendant
au minimum trois ans le maintien de
l'emploi des seniors c est l une des
volontés affichées du gouvernement ne
sont pas trop vieux à prendre au jeu et
puis on n'est pas vieux ça continue on
est en pleine forme
mais contrairement aux idées reçues il
n'y a pas de transmission de compétences
entre patrick et antoine qui ne
travaillent même pas dans le même
domaine
pour l' embauche en cdi d'antoine
l'entreprise perçoit une prime de 4000
euros pendant trois ans pour moi le
contrat de génération c'est pas c'est
entre guillemets ce que j'appelle la
cerise sur le gâteau ça veut dire que si
on n'a pas d'opportunités en termes
d'emploi on va pas faire un cdi pour le
plaisir de le voir une prime
il faut qu'ils aient des besoins c'est
clair que ça peut être le coup de pouce
déclencheur qui va nous faire aller de
l'avant qui va faire déclencher embauche
en cdi oui c'est clair
au sein de cette entreprise de 150
salariés de contrat de génération déjà
été conclus magnum n'est donc pas
concernée par le nouveau dispositif voté
par les députés
un dispositif qui oblige les moyennes
entreprises à conclure un accord sur
l'emploi des jeunes et des seniors sous
peine de sanctions le drh voit ces
nouvelles contraintes d'un mauvais oeil
on peut pas être que dans la contrainte
voilà je trouve que c'est
c'est l'entreprise c'est c'est si on va
lui sur le métro de contraintes à
l'entreprise
et bien il y aura plus d'entreprises
pour le gouvernement il s'agit de
multiplier les contrats de génération
espérait ainsi se rapprocher de
l'objectif
cinq cent mille contrats durant le
quinquennat voilà karine perrelle de la
lfp
oui donc on a vu que dans certaines
entreprises le contrat de génération
fonctionner mais dans les entreprises
moyennes
il ne fonctionne pas il est loin loin
loin des objectifs fixés
est ce qu'une des solutions se serait
pas finalement de m ce contrat dans le
pacte de l'introduire dans le pacte de
responsabilité dans la partie
contreparties demandées aux entreprises
c'est une solution mais faire mieux
encore parce qu'il faut aller plus vite
je vais vous décrire des choses mais
d'abord juste un petit point sur le
contrat de génération parce que
j'entends tout le temps ça démarre pas
ça marche pas et ses ailes de rengaines
comme si rien ne bougeait donc ça marche
extrêmement bien on vient de le voir
dans les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés parce que dans les entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés c'est très
simple à mettre en oeuvre
il suffit de décider on remplit un
papier il ya le nom du jeune le nom du
plus âgé qui ont mais en se fasse et on
a le contrat de son choix sur un
objectif de 75 donc les 20000 sont
principalement pour ne pas dire
quasiment exclusivement 20000 dans les
moins de 50 salariés c'est à dire un
tiers du potentiel si je voulais dire
autrement si tout le monde l'avait mis
en place de la même manière vous x 3 on
est à un rythme de l'ordre de 60 à 70
milles donc pas très loin du rythme que
nous souhaitons qui est celui de 75000
donc dans les petites entreprises ça
marche très bien dans les très grandes
entreprises aux grands aux plus de 300
ça marche aussi pour une raison simple
c'est que c'est obligatoire et donc
cette obligation elle est en train
d'être remplies par toutes les
entreprises je ferai le compte à la fin
mai ce sont des plusieurs dizaines je
crois même plusieurs sur trois ans
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
promesse d'embauché qui ont été signés
reste et vous avez parfaitement raison
la cible qui pourtant très importante
sur le territoire français des 50 à 300
là c'est pareil on vous reproche de
vouloir passer à la contrainte quoi mais
vous savez
je passerais bien compris des reproches
donc il vaut mieux repartir du texte
pour regarder ce que l'assemblée
nationale a décidé elle a décidé de
faire en ouvrir à toutes ces entreprises
de 50 à 33 cents le bénéfice du contrat
génération sans aucune démarche
préalable
ça sera aussi simple entre 50 et 300 que
c'est simple en dessous de 50 voilà la
principale mesure on ouvre en
simplifiant au maximum de 50 actions
d'entreprises avec une entreprise non
non non non non non non on va pas
pénaliser une entreprise qu'il
embaucherait pas en contrat de
génération toutes les entreprises ne
peuvent pas embaucher un contrat j'ai
devant une entreprise qui n'a pas de
seniors par exemple quelqu'un de plus de
55 ne peut pas le faire donc ce qui dit
raconte des balivernes en disant on va
pénaliser les sens sur la masse
salariale
c'est une baliverne donc je vous
expliquer pourquoi mais donc ce qu'ils
disent ce qu'ils vont pas mettre en
place des contrats de génération ils
vont être pénalisés ils disent n'importe
quoi
c'est ce qu'a fait monsieur copé mais il
a l'habitude de dire n'importe quoi donc
c'est double zéro en politique la ses
triples 0 une troisième l'erreur en
politique qu'est ce que nous avons
décidé de faire avant ça a l'air d'être
un peu techno mais enfin avant la can au
contrat de génération il existait il
existait une obligation entre 50 et 300
salariés de négocier un plan senior qui
a été fusionné avec le contrat de
génération nous remettons en place cette
obligation qui existait auparavant
donc on remet en place sinon ce serait
un moins dans l'entrevue on remet en
place cette obligation de négociation
dans l'entreprise ou surtout dans la
branche quand l'obligation existait
c'est extraordinaire toutes les branches
avaient conclu des accords seniors et
bien tous les courants qui n'est pas
couverte à la biennale dédiée comme
auparavant
comme auparavant comme du temps de
monsieur copé comme du temps de monsieur
fillon comme du temps de tous ceux qui
ont précédé qui ont mis en place ces
accords signés en ce moment qu'ils
avaient mis en place c'est eux il y a
une politique mais elle ne marche pas
c'est la fin on la met pas en place
ah parce que tout le monde on ne la met
pas en place parce que c'est ce qui se
passe tout le monde avait intérêt sans
aller les contrats moins techno greta
qui nous est accordée
du genre on oblige les entreprises à
embaucher d'autres contrats géants du
secteur
une des solutions serait pas de même
dans le tact valeur sabilité mieux parce
qu'on va faire plus vite puisque c'est
dans la loi sur la formation
professionnelle
ça passe au sénat et d'ici à la fin de
ce mois les la décision sera prise donc
ça va être ouvert après que dans le
pacte lui-même il y ait un enjeu
considérable sur la place des jeunes
leur embauche de jeunes l'embauché en
apprentissage
l'alternance oui c'est une des
contreparties pour reprendre le terme
qui semble-t-il ne plaît pas à tout le
monde
une des contreparties qui doit pouvoir
être négocié par les partenaires
eux-mêmes dans le cadre de ce pacte de
responsabilité une des responsabilités
c'est plus de place pour les jeunes plus
de place pour les seniors parce que vous
avez fait allusion à la la version de la
courbe du chômage on était à quelques
millimètres mais après tu entends
différence entre être au dessus ou en
dessous la barre mais juste avant les
seniors c'est le vrai gros problème
aujourd'hui du chômage va franchement
somme le chômage des jeunes
il a reculé cette année en 2001 il a
reculé
il y en a moins aujourd'hui que au début
de l'année 2003 il a reculé par contre
le chômage des seniors lui il a continué
à augmenter alors ces dons et le chômage
à l'auditoire un peu avant de revenir
les plus âgés les responsabilités à ce
temps vous pouvez nous dire là michel
sapin quand est ce que la cob va
s'inverser nous je veux pas être le cas
moi je le dit autrement le chômage
logiquement le chômage doit reculer ce
label chômage reculera c'est à gré a
reculé pour les jeunes il va continuer à
reculer pour les en remercie on en
février la venue de cette année mais je
ne suis pas dans la question d inversion
de la courbe ça la version de la coupe
c'est quand on veut que le mouvement
s'inverse
maintenant on n'est pas dans la version
il faut que le chômage recueilli savez
ce que nous avons obtenu par des
politiques qui sont des politiques
volontaristes ont parlé de contrat de
génération pourrait pas et des emplois
d'avenir
c'est à dire faire reculer le chômage
des jeunes ça c'est obtenu on va
continuer on doit obtenir pour tous donc
s'appeler sera cette année bolide nous
voulons que le chômage en baisse en
soyons clair ça sera taxée club 1
les chômeurs ont levé tous mais il n'y a
pas besoin de prendre une dot la version
elle est derrière nous on y était
presque la version c'est pas la question
c'est pas la version la version est là
pour les moins de 50 le recul du chômage
il est là pour les jeunes de moins de 25
ans après il ya ceux qui ont plus de 50
ans c'est un vrai problème c'est là
qu'il faut faire peser y compris dans le
cadre de contes du contrat du pacte de
responsabilité
la contrepartie ça me paraît très très
important mais on faire reculer le
chômage or le pacte de responsabilité
ça ce temps ça se tend aujourd'hui on a
le patron du medef qui est dans les
bagages de françois hollande aux états
unis et qui en fait un outil qui dit qui
dit il est pas question et je veux pas
entendre de contrepartie je ne veux rien
de contraignant l'économie c'est pas la
cour d'école alors est ce qu'il donne
pas l'impression de torpiller la
négociation qui doit s'ouvrir d'ici la
fin du mois avec les partenaires sociaux
on avait aussi ce matin le patron de la
cfdt qui disait il faut une réunion
d'urgence avec le patronat est ce que
vous ce qui a le feu ce qu'il faut une
réunion d'urgence avec le patronat
qu'est-ce qu'on l'attendait déjà appuyé
à matha une espèce de le faire
maintenant je travaille et on a rejoué
répond dans le pacte responsabilité il
ya le mot responsabilité est donc dans
cette période comme plus tard chacun
doit être responsable se comporter de
manière responsable
y compris et j'allais dire surtout à
l'étranger parler de manière responsable
ce sont des sujets difficiles ce sont
des sujets pas simplement entre le
patronat ou le medef et le gouvernement
même si c'est un sujet qu'on peut
discuter mais ça concerne aussi d'autres
grandes organisations patronales les
artisans ou les sages et pm et ça
concerne les organisations syndicales
donc que chacun s'exprime de manière
responsable c'est pas moi qui ai inventé
le terme de pacte de responsabilité mais
cette responsabilité elle doit assumer
par tous et à tout moment
les mots ont un sens car les mots et un
poids japon je rappelle à la
responsabilité de chacun quant à la
demande de monsieur bergé qui est
parfaitement légitime
ça n'est pas une demande en urgence en
réponse un propos washingtonia ou je ne
sais pas d'où
et de postes mauvais réveil ce est une
demande qui est une demande parfaitement
légitime puisque le patronat a demandé à
la suite d'une sollicitation du
gouvernement aux autres partenaires
sociaux aux autres syndicats de se
réunir d'ici à la fin du mois de février
la fin du mois de février c'était
peut-être un peu loin tout le monde veut
aller vite
le patronat a dit province il faut aller
vite parce qu'on veut qu'à fin février
il ait confusion de leur part et qu'à
fin mars 2 le contour du pacte de
responsabilité soient totalement défini
maintenant c'est une affaire entre ce
qu'on appelle les partenaires sur entre
représentants du patronat et le medef
ont remis cela et représentants des
syndicats parce que c'est eux les mieux
placés pour dire ce que c'est qu'une
contrepartie c'est pas des chiffres
comme ça qu'on jette comme ça en l'air y
en aura passé à partir du côté du matin
ils veulent pas en entendre parler et
même ils vont plus loin de tenue
j'espère pour vous que vous aurez
l'occasion de m'interroger de nouveau et
d'interroger monsieur gattaz sur des
contreparties
parce que c'est pas un sujet qui clôt
par une déclaration prématurée est un
peu rapide donc le sujet mais les idées
sur la table
il n'est pas du tout dans la notion du
donnant donnant vous n'avez pas entendu
si puisqu'il n'a même pas été enregistré
6 ici on l'attendait on l'a entendu
contre alpha de contrat de cotiser quand
vous dites j'irais attrait la
responsable j'arrête
j'appelle à la responsabilité chacun
mais jos où lorsqu'on est responsable
lui aussi grande organisation qu'elle a
la responsabilité en disant c'est pas
parce qu'on baisse les charges qu'on
peut créer de l'emploi forcément c'est
comme ça que marche des gueux ne mérite
pas l'appel à la responsabilité c'est
l'appel au raisonnement
le raisonnement est autre chose on ne
peut pas dire comme ça globalement
puisque on baisse les cotisations ça va
faire tant d'emplois d'ailleurs le
premier qui a agi comme ça qui est
toujours le même avec un million ici à
la boutonnière avec un pin's a lancé le
débat pas forcément de la bonne manière
lui même et il est en train de dire ma
tante ressentent de traîtres aux pédales
et autres j'ai mis un million là mais je
peux pas m'engager sur ce griffon vie
mais bon il se le dit un peu à lui-même
c'est une sorte de rappel à lui-même
comme on peut faire et c'est ça les
partenaires sociaux ils sont vont ils
vont en discuter
c'est quand même plus simple de dire par
filière ça veut dire quoi par filière il
y a des ya des domaines où l'enjeu c'est
qu'on arrête et destructions d'emplois
donc on va pas dire là la contrepartie
c'est de créer non c'est d'arrêter de
détruire il ya des endroits où l'enjeu
c'est de maintenir l'emploi
et puis il ya des endroits qui sont ou
l'enjeu c'est de créer des emplois des
endroits quand je dis des endroits c'est
dans la métallurgie
combien at on créé d'emplois dans le
bâtiment combien peut-on proposer 30
millions tel ou tel en 2010 peut-on
créer baisse de charges patronales
le président du medef de menthe l'adula
koné seuls 60 milliards est-ce que là
aussi c'est une hérésie
l'irresponsabilité c'est déjà moins
puisque avant ils demandaient son
milliard donc vous voyez comme quoi
quand on commence à discuter on peut
devenir raisonnable et responsable les
chiffres puisque vous parliez des
créations d'emplois votre collègue au
gouvernement arnaud montebourg dit
justement dans le donnant donnant on
pense que enfin lui il chiffre à 1,6
million mais c'est possible écrit le
raisonnement si vous le souhaitez mais
un chiffre global ça illustre bien le
cedus trop bien l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est de
l'emploi et l'emploi en plus un million
ou un million six c'est ce que nous
avons fait du temps que jospin on a fait
même plus que ça tant que je serai en
nombre de créations d'emplois donc c'est
faisable
on n'est pas dans de l'utopie on est
dans quelque chose qui est du
raisonnable
après il faut être opérationnel il faut
être concret ça se regarde entreprise
par entreprise
ça se regarde branche par contre ça se
regarde même territoire par territoire
parce que je veux que au niveau des
territoires les patrons et les syndicats
ils discutent des enjeux et puis il n'ya
pas que la question de combien d'emplois
moi je veux pas de la création de mini
jobs
je veux pas que dans le million
d'emplois en question ce soit des
emplois d'intérimaires des emplois de
cdd des emplois à temps partiel la
méthode al anglaise c'est pas notre
méthode allemand la méthode ou l
allemand dont ils sont en train de
revenir puisque justement ils veulent
mettre en place le smig ils veulent
lutter contre ce ce mauvais emploi comme
ils le disent eux-mêmes donc je veux que
le million d'emplois ou au delà ou en
deçà on verra ce soit du bon emploi
d'accord
deux questions encore qui est un proche
de françois hollande est ce que vous
pensez que le président a eu raison de
faire confiance au medef
au risque de mécontenter son électorat
mais à six semaines des élections
municipales mais la confiance quand on
est dans le domaine social il y à des
patrons il y a des syndicats je ne
choisis pas les patrons ou je ne choisis
pas les syndicats c'est une donnée c'est
une donnée est ce qui me donnait
d'ailleurs je comment dirais-je
appréciable du paysage français
donc il ya trois organisations
patronales représentatives au niveau
national
c'est avec ces trois que nous discutons
il y a cinq organisations syndicales
représentatives au niveau national
depuis la cftc jusqu'à la cgt en passant
par fo la cftc la cgc la cfdt bien vous
êtes donc ça c'est une donnée et c'est
cette donnée là que nous mais nous avons
la folie le dialogue social il
renforçait doute quoi on y vend le
patronat est d'accord ils vont à la
baisse de charge mais promet rien est ce
que c'est parce que c'est une question
politique montre aussi que c'est
possible vous le voyez mais avec la
gauche ps c'est peut être question de la
gauche du ps elle dit comme d'habitude
la même chose je veux pas lui reprocher
puisque on sait très bien à l'avant ce
qu'elles valaient que non si la gauche
du ps représenter les électeurs du père
ça serait bien donc ça n'est pas ça
dépasse mes cd en plus mes pensées qui
est parfaitement respectable je n'ai pas
de débat c'est vrai débat comme on avons
toujours eu au sein du ps le jour où il
y aura plus de débat au sein du ps vous
viendrez moi que ça voudrait dire qu'il
ya plus de ps
donc je souhaite qu'il jouera dbs et
avec du débat à l'apn du ps non
simplement ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui
c'est pas de faire de la politique c'est
de faire de l'économie qui soient utiles
aux plans justement donc quelles sont
les bonnes décisions qui permettent de
faire en sorte que les entreprises parce
que c'est dans les entreprises que
maintenant il faut créer des emplois que
ces entreprises créent des emplois
merci karine justement matin une
information vous pourriez nous confirmer
que l'apprentissage serait le grand
perdant de la lutte pour l'emploi
puisque on a lu dans le figaro qu' il y
avait moins 8,1 pour cent l'an dernier
devant janot de la tcc de continuer à
lire le figaro b ne pas de lire que le
figaro c'est aussi le vous risquez
d'avoir une vidéo justement
il était alors le chiffre la vérité
c'est à la baisse je peux dire ça faire
appel si cnas et la baisse jeudi les
chiffres
aujourd'hui il y à 2 % 2 % de contrats
de personnes en apprentissage en moins
par rapport à l'année dernière
c'est trop 2% mais ça n'est que 2 % donc
on va arrêter de dire que ça s'est
écroulé ensuite pourquoi n'en sont pas
moins 8 - de sifflet l'information à je
vaux je vous dis bien les choses
aujourd'hui il y as en apprentissage 2 %
de personnes deux mois par rapport à
l'année dernière
ces 2 personnes 2 % de trop et ça n'est
que vous avez % de contrats signés en
moins on parle bien de conduite est ce
que c'est parce que certains ont été
signés plus tôt fin je veux pas rentrer
dans les ca concédé principalement dues
comme ça a été le cas déjà par ailleurs
en 2009 à des questions sur l'activité
économique cote
les entreprises ont des inquiétudes en
termes d'emplois elles embauchent moins
d'après crise est normal puisque
l'apprenti c'est un emploi c'est un
contrat c'est pas c'est pas un jeu un
stagiaire
c'est quelqu'un qui est en contrat de
travail dans l'entreprise c'est la
première raison la deuxième raison c'est
qu'il faut qu'ils aient plus d'argent
qu'ils aillent vers l'apprentissage
un des éléments de la réforme de la
formation professionnelle que nous
allons discuter au sénat c'est faire en
sorte qu'ils aient plus d'argent de
l'apprentissage qui aille à
l'apprentissage louis a besoin d'un
effort supplémentaire en faveur de
servir stocker plus de frontières 6/4 et
une paire et arnaud arrive tout de suite
donc juste après d'abord ce reflet des
états d'âme qui se répand dans les rangs
socialistes et je le sapin en raison
notamment des biens de ceux certains
ratés du gouvernement sandra cerqueira
de quoi quand démenti ainsi va la vie au
gouvernement jean marc ayrault après
avoir déjeuné avec le président annonce
le retrait de la loi famille renvoyer à
des jours meilleurs
trois jours plus tard le même jean marc
ayrault se dit prêt à examiner sans
tarder certaines dispositions du texte
après la reculade le rétropédalage
où est la cohérence se demandent les
élus ps consterné le gouvernement après
une partie de sa majorité de court et ça
ne passe pas pour
ton ces débats là mais nous disons pas
on repousse on avance etc
on essaie d'avancer sur toutes les
questions de front les français
attendent cela de nous aussi les
socialistes s'inquiètent et réclame
encore et toujours un changement de
méthode
quand ils ne dénoncent pas un manque
d'autorité faut toujours être vigilant
besson à six semaines des municipales
cela s'appelle jouer avec le feu le
risque c'est l'abstention
sans compter que le virage du pacte de
responsabilité pour et braquer les
électeurs de gauche
les flottements en fait qu' il n'y a pas
de mobilisation du camp de la gauche
pour défendre nos réformes
la pression de la droite et de l'extrême
droite soper de plus en plus elle est à
partir de là et bien on a l'impression
que c'est un peu la godille ici ou là
voilà le gouvernement aux longues audi
un désordre qui fait plonger un peu plus
la cote de confiance du chef de l'état
tombée en dessous des 20% symbolique le
premier ministre davis également mêmes
manuel valls le plus populaire des
ministres jusque là épargné voit sa
popularité en chute libre à perrine
tarneaud dont on va vous allez pouvoir
répondre
gbèdan d'autres donc voyez je n'accorde
pas d'importance mais présent la
république à 19%
est-ce qu'on peut encore imposer ses
réformes et suffisamment fait je vois
pas quelle est la relation entre un
sondage hdy de popularité qui n'a pas de
sens électorale direct et la capacité à
agir
mais si tous les chefs gouvernement sauf
si tous les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement dans l'europe qui va mal
regardez quelle est leur cote de
popularité est ce qu'ils vont s'arrêter
pour autant d'agir non il faut agir
qu'est-ce qui sera jugé le moment venu
le moment venu c'est à la fin du
quinquennat c'est le président la
république l'action de sa majorité
c'est le résultat d'une politique c'est
pas le cheminement de cette politique
c'est le résultat de cette politique
d'où l'importance de prendre des
décisions de les prendre le plus
rapidement possible de la manière la
plus réfléchie possible et de les porter
de la manière la plus efficace possible
oui faire comprendre le sens d'une
décision le sens d'une réforme c'est
aussi très important et pourtant 21
points alors que toutes les portes en 21
ans après l'élection présidentielle
il ya toujours cette image d'amateurisme
qui colle au gouvernement
il y a du mal à se décoller de cette
image pourquoi ça ne marche toujours pas
selon vous et je peu après ont parlé
d'amateurisme donc j'entendais encore
les unes des hebdos si je devais juger
l'action de son domaine alors ces
contenus ou du précédent je ne m'en
remettrai pas uniquement aux unes des
magazines qui sont là et je le comprends
tout à fait pour faire vendre
donc effectivement si vous faites j'ai
eu dans dix ans tout va bien savant pas
si vous dites tout va mal ça va mieux
c'est parti trois fois de suite parce
que le monde et on vend plus son journal
donc il faut aussi faire attention à la
subtilité dans le dans le coup ça mais
je ne vais pas vous dire je vais donc la
situation est difficile pour le pays la
situation mérite des efforts dans des
moments où c'est difficile et où il ya
des efforts à faire c'est rare que les
gouvernements soient pour reprendre le
terme populaire c'est pas pour autant
qu'ils sont pas respectées nous avons un
président de la république il est là
jusqu'en 2017
nous avons un gouvernement il sera là
avec une majorité il ya une majorité au
sein du parlement et quelles que soient
les débats qui peuvent exister
bien entendu on donne beaucoup plus
souvent la parole à ceux qui critiquent
c'est normal c'est plus intéressant
d'entendre une critique c'est normal
une majorité qui est là jusqu'en 2010
gouvernement qui est une majorité qui
soutient le gouvernement qui est nommé
par le président réplique donc ça c'est
une donnée institutionnels c'est la
cinquième république elle est ainsi fait
et heureusement parce qu'elle permet de
donner de la durée pour traverser des
moments extrêmement difficiles voir ce
que traverse la france aujourd'hui mais
en s'y reprend l'histoire autour du
projet de loi famille un gouvernement
qui cède à la pression de l'arrivée ce
que c'est un aveu de faiblesse
non parce que ça c'est la manière dont
vous le présentez c'est comme si c'était
une réponse à la rue c'était pas une
réponse à la rue c'est une alliance
s'acquiert c'est une réponse à une
tension dans la société à des situations
quand on veut bien réformé il vaut mieux
éviter de le faire à un moment où il ya
des faux débat quand vous il y avait des
rumeurs aussi jamais employer un terme
mal polis mais aussi infondée et aussi
scandaleuse que celles qui ont été
répandues et hacker laquelle la droite
et gauche et la droite parlementaire a
donné aussi son appui et qui font qu'il
ya des parents peut-être de bonne foi
qu'ils retirent leurs enfants de l'école
parce qu'ils craignent je ne sais trop
quel enseignement c'est scandaleux
on ne peut pas réformer dans un contexte
comme celui donc j'ai repris déjà j'ai
des expressions ce dimanche tant dans le
parisien libéré il ya main du moment il
faut des temps morts je vends le geste
parce que c'est le geste au basket je
vais jouer au basket au compteur taille
donc vous devez savoir de quoi vous
aussi vous étiez dans l'équipe de
feuillet bon ben voilà il ya temps mort
la ja temps mort parce qu'il faut que
retrouver un peu de calme de sérénité
pour repartir de l'avant
c'est pas reculer c'est repartir de
l'avant pour répondre à des problèmes
très concrets
est ce que les familles d'aujourd'hui
fonctionne comme les familles d'il ya 20
ans 30 ans ou 50 ans non en région
parisienne la moitié des familles sont
issus de familles
enfin ce sont des familles recomposées
c'est quand même à une donnée
sociologique que chacun d'entre nous
peut comprendre et qui peut avoir des
conséquences juridiques pour établir les
droits des salaires des autres mais
quand même sous le sapin on est loin de
la france apaisée et rassembler promise
par françois hollande pendant la
campagne présidentielle
en tous les cas c'est pas la france que
lui va chercher si je puis dire
nicolas sarkozy il est résulté un coup
de main oui nicolas sarkozy il allait
chercher le le conflit il provoqué le
conflit
ils faisaient siffler dans les meetings
les organisations patronales comme une
variation syndicale ça c'est pas une
manière apaisée de faire là ce qui se
passe et c'est vrai pour toute la
société politique qu'elles soient de
gauche ou qu'elle se drogue dès lors
qu'elle est républicaine il y à de
mauvais fond il y à de mauvais roland il
ya parfois même des expressions qui sont
des expressions n'ont pas d'opinion mais
qui sont des délits lilian et souffrant
soldes ne sont pas menées sous françois
hollande s'en sont pas nues et je vous
pardonne son panonceau françois hollande
ils étaient là avant aujourd'hui
s'exprime ils s'expriment ils doivent
être combattus et quel est le problème
c'est qu'ils ne sont pas combattu par
toute la société républicaine parce
qu'il y en a à droite je vois monsieur
copé par exemple
dimanche dernier qui font qu'ils donnent
des fondements à tout cela au lieu de
combattre la première chose à faire
c'est de combattre le racisme
l'antisémitisme aussi ténu soit il et
doit être combattue sans faiblesse et
par tous jean françois copé quand il
brandit le livre tout ça pas les faits
la surenchère dangereuse vous trouvez
évidemment mais c'est même pire que ça
comme chacun sait si le soleil ce livre
est un livre dit vivre pour enfants qui
n'est pas un livre scolaire et
brandissent ce livre là je pourrais vous
en brandir d'autres
son délit pour enfin je vis d'exemple
les uns les autres ils pourront choisir
les rails de nombreuses publicités aux
amazones ont joui d'une grande publicité
ça doit pas choqué d'autant que chez les
uns ou les autres 8 mai surenchère
dangereuse et c'est quoi alors c'est
plus que ça il est dans le registre de
l'irresponsabilité totale je disais que
c'était double zéro maintenant cette
triple zéro quadruples 0 ils sont pas
tous comme ça l'ump je vous rassure il y
en a qui savent raisonnée et sereinement
c'est pas parce que je suis en désaccord
avec quelqu'un que je vais pour autant
dire qu'il est à chaque fois que tu peux
0 mais quand quelqu'un s'exprime comme
ça en disant n'importe quoi et en
attisant les haines et les peurs ça
n'est pas un responsable politique je
rappelle que jean françois copé avait
demandé votre démission après la nonna
version de la cour pénale même pas sa
démission de la tête de l'ump puisque
j'ai compris qu'il n'y avait été même
pas élu alors lui ajoute que je vous dit
on ne gouverne pas en fonction des
sondages même avec moins de temps pour
cent quand on est chef de l'état mais il
va y avoir bientôt les élections
intermédiaires je vous avez regardé les
sondages d'ailleurs le l'homme le plus
impopulaire dans tous les sondages
et comment il s'appelle sais pas copé
les élections intermédiaires qui arrive
avec la disent les sondages un échec
prévisible de la gauche n'est ce pas
perrine vous allez passer rien donné ni
vous ni mauvaise en face aux comédies
mais si la gauche perd les municipales
eh bien il va falloir renoncer à ses
membres de répondre par exemple la
brosse donc première chose il ya des
élections municipales
elles ont lieu on verra quel sera le
résultat je suis persuadé que la gauche
perdra certaines villes je suis sûr que
la droite perdra certaines villes donc
on verra au bout du compte ce qu'il en
est ce sont d'abord des élections
locales compte tenu des équipes
sortantes des équipes en 30 du débat
local dans un contexte politique
lui-même
évidemment il n'ya pas aucune élection
aussi locale soit elle qui se dégage du
contexte politique 9 mai on verra le
résultat je ne ressens pas moi sur le
terrain les mêmes types de critiques que
celles qui peuvent exprimer
nationalement je ne les ressent pas et
je sens aussi un attachement aux
politiques qui ont été menées par les
équipes sortantes en particulier le
pronom paris prônons lyon reprenant les
élus de gauche
l'électorat lui est donc on verra cela
et ensuite et ça a été comme ça la
dernière fois où ça a été une grande
grande défaite de la droite aux
dernières élections municipales c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui complique un petit peu
les choses pour nous c'est que c'était
une grande victoire pour la gauche les
dernières élections municipales aura
compte énormément
bon donc on ne gouverne pas en fonction
de ce résultat
la droite a continué à agir alors
qu'elle avait perdu les municipales de
cette fois ci on continuera à agir alors
qu'on n'a pas forcément permis démunis
ou l'abandon de certaines réformes de
société et là aussi je reviens au projet
loi sur la famille ça n'a pas un effet
démobilisateur important sur l'électorat
de gauche
c'est seulement la gauche du parti
socialiste c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut
bien comprendre le sens c'est pas un
recul pour un abandon s'est fait en
sorte temps mort que chacun se calme et
qu'on puisse sereinement en évitant les
fausses rumeurs et surtout en mettant la
droite devant ses responsabilités que
les vraies et bonnes décomplexée après
c'est la barre nuit est plus que
décomplexée elle se sent pour une partie
d'entre elles robin données non pas la
gauche a abandonné pour autant ce fait
ce qu'il dit est ce que toute réforme de
société du coup est désormais tanoh
évidemment pas évidemment il ya des
réformes si nécessaire
nous avons fait une grande réforme de
société avec le mariage pour tous qui
est soutenu par une grande majorité des
français y compris dans l'électorat de
droite merde parce que il y en a aussi
la de la droite qui ont envie de pouvoir
vivre librement et de faire des choix
libres y compris dans l'organisation de
leur propre couple en ce moment même où
une réunion tendue jean marc ayrault sur
l'immigration et surtout sur
l'intégration sur l'intégration ce que
c'est le bon timing pour ouvrir ces deux
éléments c'est un bon ami il ya des
questions d'intégration à tout ça n'est
pas l'air d'aller ces mêmes c'est même
un sujet qui est posé y compris dans les
municipales comment fait-on pour que une
population qui est là légalement
légalement puissent s'intégrer le plus
profondément possible dans la société
française le problème le modèle sur ce
modèle
français c'est celui de l'intégration
c'est le contraire de la
communautarisation c'est pas du tout le
modèle américain le modèle anglais le
modèle anglais récemment ces gens
sérieux je n'ai pas entendu moi je
m'exprime ici et je m'exprime je pense
pas être en différence par rapport à ce
qu'est la ligne gouvernementale le mana
et l'anglais c'est dire pour être
tranquille on les met tous dans un coin
très bien ils parlent entre eux ils ont
leurs propres magasins
c'est pas le modèle français c'est un
risque parce que l on voit des
situations de cette nature non nous
c'est l'intégration l'intégration dans
ce grand creuset qui est le creuset de
la france avec ses grands principes y
compris celui de laïcité donc de respect
de toutes les religions mais de respect
par les religions de la république tend
à nouveau souffle pour le gouvernement
il faudrait pas remanié avant les
municipales
je ne le crois pas non mais de tout
temps récent de ségolène royal je ne le
crois pas mais de toute façon je vais
vous faire un aveu
ça ne dépend absolument pas dans
violente et ça ne dépend pas de vous ni
nous c'est vrai ça vous pose quand même
la question
merci beaucoup merci perrine merci
devrait être avec lui au monsieur
michelin du travail la semaine prochaine
c'est marine le pen qui sera l'invité de
notre rendez vous sur public sénat avec
l agence france presse et dailymotion a
très vite